give directly is the non-profit that
lets you send cash directly to the
world's poorest household which is more
cost effective than so many other types
of giving it's how you know you're
maximizing your donations help us reach
our goal of fifteen thousand dollars by
the end of the year go to give
directly.org Pacman
well it's so great to start with some
good news today Raphael Warnock has
defeated Herschel Walker in the Georgia
Senate runoff this means that Democrats
will control the Senate 51-49 rather
than 50 50. this has a number of
important consequences which we are of
course going to talk about but the big
news is that it did not go the way of
Donald Trump and of Maga and of the
Herschel Walker endorsement industrial
complex wing of the Republican Party
Georgia Senate runoff election results
Warnock 51.4 Walker 48.6 now
I am with everybody in the audience in
particular many of our viewers from
around the world who look at Herschel
Walker and they say
how does this guy even have a shot in a
state like Georgia with a population
voting population in the millions how
does this guy not lose by 70 even as
deranged and ignorant as the Republican
Party electorate is in the United States
and of course that horrifies me as well
this is a guy who shouldn't even have
had a shot and yet he came within under
a hundred thousand votes in the runoff
of becoming one of 100 senators in the
United States we're not going to fix the
United States in that sense right here
in this segment so I won't dwell on that
uh too too much Democratic senator
Warnock wins Georgia runoff against
Walker reports the Associated Press and
indeed now control of the Senate will be
not only excuse me
I'm almost back from covid but not a
hundred percent uh it will be not 50 50
but it will be 51 to 49 and there are so
many reasons that that is hugely
important which I will get to but first
let's look at a couple of Clips here are
the calls from the three major networks
what does this look like Statewide well
I'll I'll let you take it from there
because I think there's some news there
that check mark is a consequential thing
NBC News
incumbent Democrat Rafael Warnock
Governor uh we have seen changes all
over Senator yeah we're going to
interrupt you I want to go to Jake for a
uh an announcement excellent that's
right we can now make a projection in
the final senate election of the 2022
midterm elections CNN projects the
Democratic senator Raphael Warnock will
win re-election in the Georgia Senate
runoff right now we're relying on the
Associated Press to give us these
numbers and right now the Associated
Press is just given the check mark to
Rafael Warnock is going back to the U.S
Senate as the winner of this runoff
against Herschel Walker now we will get
back to that Fox News call because it
actually happened at sort of a very very
interesting moment now we did hear from
both candidates winner and loser alike
starting with the winner Rafael Warnock
take a quick listen
[Applause]
and after a
hard-fought campaign
[Applause]
or should I say campaigns
it is my honor
to utter the four most powerful words
ever spoken in a democracy
the people have spoken
very much so in Raphael Warnock actually
talking about a number of important
points including the fact that just
because he won doesn't mean there
weren't efforts at voter suppression
which by the way is very different than
saying it was rigged I know that there
were some Republicans seizing on this
and saying look Republicans aren't the
only ones who say it was rigged that's
not what Warnock is saying there are
those who would look at the outcome of
this race
and saying that there's no voter
suppression in Georgia
let me Let Me Clear
just because people endured
long lines
that wrapped around buildings
some blocks long just because they
endured the rain and the cold
and all kinds of tricks in order to vote
doesn't mean that voter suppression does
not exist it simply means that you the
people have decided that your voices
will not be silent yeah and of course
there were attempts to suppress the vote
and we know what these are George is a
epicenter of these try to reduce early
voting they did this when it came to the
period after Thanksgiving we covered it
on the award-winning bonus show of
course oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad now we
also heard from the loser
who was Herschel Walker and there was a
question as to whether Herschel Walker
would have any idea what's even going on
like how does he even give a concession
speech and he sort of did and he said
something about the numbers aren't
adding up for him we've had a tough
Journey have we not
one of the things I said is they when
they called the race I said enormous
those look like they're going to add up
right but one of the things I want to
tell all of you is you never stop
dreaming I don't want any of you to stop
dreaming I don't want any of you to stop
believing in America I want you to
believe in America and continue to
believe in the Constitution and believe
in our elected officials most of all
well that belief is slightly reinforced
by the fact that this guy fortunately is
not going to be a U.S senator continue
to pray for them because all the prayers
you've given me I felt those prayers I
want to thank apparently they were not
quite enough follow my team as well team
Herschel because they put up with a lot
and I want to thank team harshall thank
all my donors as well because you guys
without you I couldn't have done what
I've done yep so a sort of uh concession
speech from Herschel Walker and then
maybe the most important Point reminding
himself he's still sort of a winner
right
we all winners so we're all winners and
that's what I want to say we're all
winners and I want to say God is a good
god yep everybody won at the end of the
day everybody won at the end of the day
um Donald Trump's reaction not pleased
tweeting in of tweeting trophing of
course on Truth social truth essential
our country is in big trouble what a
mess now the importance of 5149 rather
than 50 50. because either way it would
be a democratic majority because Kamala
Harris in a 50 50 tie is the
tie-breaking vote and she still would be
the tie-breaking vote if there is a 50
50 tie in the Senate but 5149 means
Democrats don't have to negotiate a
power sharing arrangement with the
Senate minority leader Mitch McConnell
that's a great thing number two there's
no one Senator veto power okay now it's
two so at 50 50. Joe manchin alone or
Kirsten Cinema alone becomes sort of one
senator vetoers now there's no one
Senator veto power it's two but that's
still a better situation committees is
the third issue because of the current
power sharing agreement with the equal
Senate split any tie on a committee goes
to a full Senate vote now Democrats
still have the majority but if you have
a committee with 16 members and you have
an eight and eight uh split and you have
an eight to eight vote that committee
vote now has to go to the full Senate
where if it's 50 50 in comes Kamala
Harris and breaks the tie it's just
going to be much faster because having a
majority on the Committees more than
likely Democrats will have a one-seat
majority on every committee you skip
that entire dog and pony show still it's
a majority either way but it would be
much more annoying with the 50 50.
um and it just makes everything faster
and then also the subpoena issuing
process will be much stronger because
you won't really need bipartisan support
to issue subpoenas that's important and
if there were to be a supreme court
vacancy we don't know it always you just
don't know depends on who who's the
nominee and what's the process when does
it happen but it's always better to have
more seats in the event that there is a
supreme court vacancy or even another
potential judicial vacancy so very
important Maga and shambles and we will
talk about that but first let's talk
about Laura Ingram on Fox News who had a
really bad night last night
there's this amazing moment uh last
night from Fox News where uh Laura
Ingram is ranting and raving and all of
a sudden
it doesn't go well for Herschel Walker
and she kind of loses it so first and
foremost uh let's go to the moment at uh
which Laura Ingram is ranting and raving
and kind of ginning up a conspiracy
theory of some kind and then
um all of a sudden it's announced that
Herschel Walker has lost check this out
guys uh we appreciate it Bill uh stay
with us all right sorry this is not the
right clip here is the right clip
why is it that the heavily
heavily are always the last ones to
report very suspicious isn't it Bill
Hammer I mean presumably they can't they
count and there are numbers and they
count they're more people obviously but
it seems like it kind of this is I hate
to say this is just a familiar refrain
but it's a very familiar refrain to us
isn't it suspicious election night pass
to just the midterms uh Etc I'm gonna
say that that's that's where you find
the people
um that's where they live and Laura
right now we're relying on the
Associated Press to give us these
numbers and right now the Associated
Press is just given the check mark to
Raphael Warner is going back to the U.S
Senate as the winner of this runoff
against Herschel Walker right now at
50.4 percent to Walker's 49.6 Raphael
Warnock has won the runoff in Georgia
four weeks after Sinbad I just love that
as Laura Ingram is starting to go all
conspiratorial I don't know the blue
areas take longer to give us their votes
sorry Laura let me interrupt your
conspiracy to mention that Herschel
Walker has lost this race and Raphael
Warnock has won now later on in the
night
Laura Ingram is clearly very worried and
this is this really is a pleasure to
watch I wanted to start this at the 125
Mark which is here take a listen made
and yeah nothing seems to be changing
but you didn't see a lot of enthusiasm
down there of course the spending was
completely yeah it was just look at how
close it was though I mean what did we
say this was winnable
Kelly do you you want Rhonda McDaniel I
like Ronald McDaniel took this like a
warning sign flashing are we just gonna
oh Laura's worried and she should be
doing the same thing all over again
every single election Kevin McCarthy won
the house he won the house yes he did
and we were out spent three to one here
why no excuse there's no excuse in
Georgia for us not to have done what
Brian Kemp did yes he's the incumbent
Governor he's very popular he's running
against Stacey Abrams but he turned out
over his micro targeting plan his
Grassroots people and I guess at Mitch
McConnell's group funded it but they did
that in the last couple of days
all right so Laura Ingram visibly
worried and then it gets a little tense
with kellyanne Conway she is not taking
the loss well and she's starting to take
it out on kellyanne Conway which I love
we don't Bank ballads early we're going
to keep moving it's not but we didn't
but we didn't do it in 2020 because
everyone said don't vote early because
that's correct not everyone well I think
a lot of people did at the very top of
the Republican party people did but
Molly Mitch McConnell did give 11
million to the effort that's 14 million
to the effort in Georgia but where was
all hands on deck you get Lindsey Graham
he was there he did a lot every Senator
should have been every female senator
but why I'm going to ask the question
tonight nobody wants to talk about this
why weren't they down there right well
part of it is Herschel Walker was a
disastrous candidate and Republicans as
it became clear that the December 6
runoff was no longer necessary for
Democrats to control Democrats were
going to control the Senate either way
once that became clear
some Republicans who are marginally more
Tethered to reality realized this guy's
a humiliating candidate he can't speak
he can't think he's a hypocrite he's
going around urging women to get
abortions even though he says he's
against abortions and he's saying he's a
police officer when he's not and he's
saying he trained with the FBI when he
didn't and on and on and on
why are they going to Hitch their wagon
to this horse why are they going to go
out on a limb when either way they're
not going to have control of the Senate
if Herschel Walker wins that's why they
weren't there and it was a complete and
total disaster but you know in a normal
country Walker never would have even won
a primary he was only even there because
of the atrocity that is the Republican
party so a tough night for Laura Ingram
it is what it is fortunately we are now
Beyond this Democrats will control 51-49
it gives a little bit more
the you know calmness to some
hypothetical scenarios Republicans will
have the house and we're going to have
an obstruction filled two years we will
take a quick break make sure you were
subscribed on YouTube it is free we need
your subscription on YouTube you can
vote multiple times on YouTube when it
comes to elections you can't you get one
vote many people have a couple Google
accounts you can subscribe to the
YouTube channel with each and every
account it's completely legal you won't
go to jail even if you get caught
youtube.com the davidpackman show help
us get to 2 million subscribers we're
going to take a quick break and I have
so many other things to cover with you
today
I have done a ton of reading about how
to optimize charitable donations we all
have some limited amount we can give and
for me it's important to make sure I'm
giving in the most efficient way when
organizations give cash to families in
need about 90 cents on the dollar
actually goes to the recipient instead
of only about 50 cents of relative
impact with some of the more complex
programs like certain kinds of job
training for example that's why I
reached out to an amazing non-profit
called give directly about partnering
with us because give directly lets you
send cash directly to the world's
poorest households the David packman
show is trying to hit fifteen thousand
dollars in donations to give directly
before the year is up that's equal to
about a Year's worth of expenses and
Investments for 15 families in many
cases use the link below giving families
cash lets them choose for themselves
elves how to improve their lives they
buy food they repair their homes they
start a business they buy medication
they pay for their kids schools give
directly is doing truly incredible work
all around the world when you give to
them you're maximizing every hard-earned
dollar that you donate and they need
your help go to give
directly.org Pacman help us get to
fifteen thousand dollars by the end of
the year the link is down below
folks now is the time as we have gotten
beyond the 2022 midterms 2024 and what
are going to be two years of obstruction
are now in Focus we need to build the
ecosystem and the infrastructure and
whether it's this show or other
Progressive shows I would encourage you
support someone that you think is doing
good work if you want it to be this show
I'd be flattered and you can sign up at
joinpakman.com we do an extra show every
single day for our paid members we offer
a commercial free audio and video stream
of the show custom private podcast URL
uh members only Town Halls so many
exciting things sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now to get yourself a
discount all right I I want to look at a
couple different things that my
colleague John actually sent me some of
you may remember this uh black Maga
Pastor Jesse Lee Peterson he's been on
the program before I've been on his show
before in Los Angeles California he
recently was involved in I think it's
fair to call it a scandal where despite
leading a life of public homophobic
advocacy about being gay is bad and
immoral and all these different things
it appears that Jesse Lee Peterson
himself is is gay and
um this exploded in controversy several
months ago somehow Jesse Lee Peterson
ended up on the Dr Phil show now I'm
gonna be totally up front I I don't
think much of the Dr Phil show and in
fact I had some back and forths with
them about two months ago about having
me on they wasted my time they were
completely disrespectful of my time
asking me to do a pre-interview and a
video Vlog explaining My Views a uh of
filling out providing answers to dozens
of questions then they never even told
me hey turns out we're not going to have
you on just never even followed up one
of the most unprofessional outfits I've
ever dealt with and yet I'm still going
to play this for you with peace and love
because it is so absolutely fascinating
Jesse Lee Peterson somehow ended up on
the Dr Phil Show and by the way this guy
on the screen right now is not Jesse Lee
Peterson uh I I'm aware of that
um and he just said violent disgusting
things that actually made an audience
member cry let's just jump right into
this first clip the the topic was is it
smart to have children now in the
background of all of this with Jesse Lee
Peterson is his personal situation where
he says he sell he told me he was
celibate because he's not married and it
turns out it's not just that he's not
married to a woman it's it's that he's
actually gay and is hiding these
relationships it's crazy Let's Just Jump
Right In
I I disagree with all this crap that I
hear I grew up with six brothers and
Seven Sisters
at a time when you know I grew up by the
way it's funny that they identify him as
radio host and Pastor which is like so
banal and anodyne
in the context of how whacked completely
whacked this guy is plantation in
Alabama and we grew up in a little Hut
house bathroom outside and we my family
of uh raised an amazing family children
but what the different was then it is
now is that before you have babies you
got married ah so you have the father
and a mother in the home and while the
fathers are earning a living the mother
was watching over his children and so
you were this entire routine is soap
extra hypocritical and ridiculous and
absurd given what we now know about
Jesse Lee Peterson personally it's
stunning that he still goes around and
says this stuff with a straight face
able to raise decent children we didn't
have government in our lives at the time
and so we were able to do that and in
America we were not allowed all these
illegal aliens and refugees to come into
our country so our government that we're
not taking care of folks from other
parts of the world and the families in
America we took care of ourselves I
think you've
oh my God people in the audience visibly
rolling their eyes but eventually they
cry
pretty much
pissed off everybody
but you said you said there's not
anything you've heard that you don't
think is crap so what do you think you
said what you don't think what do you
think I know that we need to restore the
family we need a smaller government
because government don't make anything
work understand that the family Jesse
Lee Peterson says must be restored which
is a man and a woman married having many
children is something that he himself
doesn't actually live by because it
appears as though he's a gay man which
is fine but he's spent decades shaming
gay men it's absolutely disgusting and
then a little bit later in the show his
comments actually so vile that they make
audience members who are immigrants
break down in tears what do you want to
say I would like just speak to you guys
directly you two
um to your point that poor children are
the worst in the world and that
immigrants are also not a good thing for
this country I'm someone who grew up in
an orphanage in Russia I lived there for
12 years and then I came to the United
States
and I've been working campus hours at
sorry at the um La food bank and in the
um skid row and I just think it's so
messed up when you guys are saying I'm
sorry I don't mean to be crying it's
okay
just talk through the tears I want to
hear what Dr Phil's like please no cry
more keep talking as you cry it's good
for the ratings do you have to say
and I've been putting in countless hours
working volunteering
for people in Skid Row but what you
don't realize for example to you that we
are not the worst people in the world
right I've been mentoring young guys
since I was 18 from the ages of 14
through 24. yeah I grew up in the inner
city of Detroit there's this weird thing
about the Dr Phil show where so we know
Jesse Lee Peterson is completely vile I
don't know that we need too much of a
commentary on that there's this weird
vibe on the Dr Phil show where it's sort
of like they try to present it like a
serious show but it kind of has like
Jerry Springer Maury Povich Vibes and I
don't know it's it's like every detail
something about the way it's filmed
something about the lighting and the
color temperature the lower thirds and
the font even I I can't exactly put my
finger on what it is but it just feels
like one of those types of shows even
though it kind of seems like they're
taking themselves seriously bizarre
stuff I don't even know
how much Dr Phil's people knew about
Jesse Lee Peterson when they had him on
but quite literally saying things so
disgusting they make members of the
audience cry strange and bizarre stuff a
republican focus group very clearly
turned on Donald Trump this is
fascinating stuff uh many of you know
pollster and focus group leader Frank
Luntz who has been uh working on and and
testing messaging and language and ideas
for the Republican party for a very long
time and recently this is about 10 days
old at this point in time
um he did a focus group with Republican
voters taking their temperature now
beyond the midterm elections about Trump
and about Trump versus DeSantis this
focus group and of course with any such
focus group there's a question of how
representative is the focus group really
it's anecdotes you're not going to get
with just a couple dozen or a dozen
people you're not going to get a fully
representative sample of some of a group
as large as the Republican voting base
but it's interesting anecdotally
nonetheless take a listen to what some
of these folks say first one word or
phrase that you use to describe Donald
Trump right now uh stay off Twitter
Jamie from Iowa I was just going to say
the same thing um you know his new one
that he's on I think he needs to take a
break from that one Becky
a narcissist Lisa
keep doing what you're doing Andrew
tired
John
unsettling
Melody
High Hopes Marie mistake
John from North Dakota
unrelenting Kathy
still right Eric devices
Jim
um overdone John from Georgia
fighter
David from California racist
Jeff from Texas
sanctimonious Oh Stacy from Indiana
who's this man
Nancy from Illinois
uh calculated
I would do the same thing now with the
governor of Florida Ron DeSantis I'm
going to go in the exact opposite order
right uh promising
Stacy from Indiana
oh geez
um
interesting Jeff from Texas badass
Kathy from Pennsylvania a leader
Eric from North Carolina hopeful
Jim from Indiana
Rising date John David from Georgia
I said tank fighter David from
California
promising
Andrew from South Carolina
leader John from California
Visionary Melody from Washington amazing
Marie from New York the future John from
North Dakota
no apologies Lisa from New York gutsy
Becky from Virginia you took care of the
party Jamie from Iowa
refreshing leader Gregory from Nevada
future of the party
so that is pretty interesting now of
course it's completely anecdotal but
that sentiment increasingly tired of
trump sick of the Antics sick of the
posts and the like
mirrored by what we are seeing in the
polls increasingly pointing more towards
the idea of Ron DeSantis as the future
of the party now as I've said before I
don't know that this is any big party to
write home about because if DeSantis
were to become the next president of the
United States there is no doubt in the
world
that he would be
about as dangerous as Trump in terms of
ideas but far more dangerous in terms of
his ability to execute because he's less
incompetent
um uh that's the the risk and so when we
think about the 2024 Republican primary
not that we vote in it by and large the
question of who do we prefer when the
primary has to be contextualized in who
are we worse off if they actually become
president of the United States and in a
way
an 80 year old incompetent Trump to me
seems less acutely dangerous than
Rhonda santis and I'm willing to have my
mind changed and my feelings may evolve
over the course of the primary remember
the primary in which Rhonda santis has
not even yet said he's participating but
I want to hear from you leave a comment
send an email info at davidpackman.com
send a tweet however you want to get in
touch smoke signals telegrams Etc let me
know what you think about this who would
actually be more dangerous if they
became president I want to hear from you
we will um look at some uh comments on
an upcoming episode of the show quick
break and then we will come back we're
going to talk about 17 guilty verdicts
against the Trump organization that's a
big story and so much more
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
major breaking news over the last 24
hours including 17 17 guilty counts for
the Trump organization in this massive
New York investigation that has been
going on for some time it involves
Trump's former CFO Alan weisselberg this
is a major story which has instantly
triggered the failed former president
but let's not get ahead of ourselves
let's go through it piece by piece New
York Times reports Trump organization
found guilty in tax fraud scheme the
former president's company had been
accused of providing off the book
benefits to Executives the testimony of
its former Chief Financial Officer
proved crucial to the case so what
exactly is it that happened
the conviction on all 17 counts after
more than a day of jury deliberations in
state supreme court in Manhattan stem
from the company's practice of Doling
out off the books perks to Executives
they receive luxury apartments leased
mercedes-benzes extra cash at Christmas
Even free cable television and they paid
taxes on none of it this is a very
simple thing my accountant has talked to
me about how this works many many times
before
imagine that you have something very
simple okay you have your business
leases you a car a beautiful vehicle
drives you around four wheels tires the
entire thing can go forwards and
backwards okay gets you where you need
to go let's imagine the leases to pick a
number 500 a month which is six thousand
dollars for the year the business pays
the six thousand dollars it's a business
expense for the business six thousand
dollars in lease costs but if that
vehicle is only available to one person
really it's considered a fringe benefit
and that six thousand dollars should be
added to that individual's W-2
and that you pay taxes on it you don't
get the six grand you get a lease worth
six thousand dollars and then you pay
taxes on that six thousand dollars now
six thousand dollars is very quaint
because what we're talking about here is
luxury apartments I believe at issue
also was educational expenses for family
members of Alan weisselberg and
potentially others so you're talking
about a lot more money this is classic
stuff and the idea that this is obscure
or in some way Petty is absurd any
reasonable account will tell you you
know this is the way that it has to go
um going back to the article the
Manhattan District Attorney's office
which prosecuted the case previously
obtained a guilty plea from the
architect of the schem Alan weisselberg
the longtime CFO and weisselberg
ultimately testified as the prosecution
star witness but never implicated Trump
very important prosecutors didn't charge
Trump but they invoked him throughout
the trial telling jurors he paid for
some of the stuff and even approved a
basic a crucial aspect of the scheme
importantly the verdict carries limited
Financial repercussions and will not
directly threaten to imperil Trump's
company but the conviction and the
prosecution's explosive claim and
closing arguments that Trump was quote
explicitly sanctioning tax fraud could
reverberate during his nascent 2024
presidential campaign and provide fodder
for political opponents so 17 guilty
verdicts but not going to imperil
Trump's company here's the report from
MSNBC as the news came in Long scheme
that would basically try to compensate
top Executives or help these Executives
what is it
guilty on all counts we have a verdict
it is guilty on all 17 counts uh just in
moments ago after about 10 hours of
deliberations and you're right Hallie
this is a case against the Trump
Corporation two entities of the Trump
Corporation there were no named
individuals former president Donald
Trump was not named but certainly this
this is his family company this is his
livelihood this is his business this is
his reputation this is all things Donald
Trump accept him being named as a
defendant in this case you might say so
that is from MSNBC CNN also had the
report of the verdict what do you know
well Victor that's right the jury just
returned to verdict guilty guilty on all
counts against both Trump corporations
entities that means that the jury after
two days of deliberations and four notes
today came back with this decisive
verdict unanimous guilty on all counts
now remember the two Trump organization
entities were accused of being involved
in a 15-year tax fraud scheme where they
gave their Executives certain Executives
off the books compensation that was
Corporate Apartments that were rent free
that was company cars that was private
school tuition for Alan Weissberg the
chief financial officers grandchildren
the jury finding the companies were
guilty on that now Donald Trump former
president was not charged in this case
but its name did come out at the trial
including on closing statements one of
the prosecutors saying that he believed
that Donald Trump had sanctioned some of
this tax fraud of course he did and as
Michael Cohen has spoken about many
times uh Trump knew exactly what was
going on 17 guilty verdicts let's now go
to Donald Trump's reaction
as predicted by anyone who has been
following the way Donald Trump behaves
for the last many years
upon the verdict of 17 guilty counts for
Donald Trump's organization in this
massive fraud case out of the Manhattan
District Attorney's Office Donald Trump
explodes first and foremost the message
posted to Twitter by Donald Trump's
soviet-style PR person Liz Harrington
and Trump in all caps calling it The
Manhattan Witch Hunt putting out the
following statement and I it's always
physically demanding to read these
things quote disappointed with the
verdict in Manhattan but will appeal
after looking at millions of pages of
documents over many years much to the
detriment of record-setting murder and
other forms of violent crime that are
taking place in New York City
those are unrelated things the
government capital G was able to get an
employee to quote plea why is plea in
quotes I don't know that's quite
literally what happened in order for a
very reduced sentence this case was
about Alan weisselberg committing tax
fraud on his personal tax returns Etc
with he and every witness repeatedly
testifying that President Trump and the
Trump family with a capital f knew
nothing about his actions which he
admits were done solely for his own
benefit and with no benefit to the two
companies why would Capital C
corporations which knew nothing about
weisselberg's personal tax returns be
prosecuted for that person's conduct
there was Reliance by us on a then
highly respected and expensive
accounting firm and Law Firm to do this
work the accounting firm also did his
personal returns which we are not even
allowed to legally View
this case is unprecedented and involved
no monetary gain to these two Capital C
corporations it is the continuing
continuation of the capital greatest
political Witch Hunt in the capital H
history of our Capital C country New
York City is a hard place to be quote
Trump as businesses and people flee our
ones capital G great Capital C City uh
none of that making a lot of sense and
the fear of course in Trump is that all
of this stuff is getting closer and
closer Trump not implicated directly
here in a legal sense but of course
Trump knows everything that goes on in
his businesses and 17 guilty verdicts
that get try against Trump is
understandably and expectedly triggering
to the failed former president and this
was not the only bad news for Donald
Trump yesterday because we learned that
the Trump Riot committee will indeed be
making criminal referrals the January
6th house committee
investigating the Trump riots
isn't going to last much longer and the
reason is that the house is being taken
over by Republicans in January because
Republicans won the 2022 midterms in the
house see how I say that without any
qualifications see how I just say
Democrats won the Senate but Republicans
won the house I don't have to rant and
Rave and say because of rigging or
because of fraud or fraud or because of
seasoned ballots or smoke ballots or
sauteed or sous vide ballots just
Republicans won the house and Democrats
won the Senate see how easy it is for me
to say that okay because that's what
happened in November
um and and really anyway because
Congress is ending and any investigative
committees would have to be
reconstituted in the next Congress the
January 6th Committee of the house is
going to end but it is not yet over they
told us some months ago that they would
come back with a couple of final
hearings sometime before the end of the
year I don't know if that's still going
to take place but yesterday there was a
very important bit of news that was
announced the house January 6 committee
has decided to make criminal referrals
let me remind you so we're all on the
same page one of the guidelines of house
committees remember the House of
Representative uh the House of
Representatives has investigative duties
and responsibilities and abilities
they do not have primary criminal
referral responsibility meaning the
house is not supposed to take on an
investigation
primarily or solely to determine whether
Criminal activity took place however it
is well within the purview of the House
of Representatives investigative duties
to make criminal referrals if in
investigating whatever they are
investigating they come across what they
believe to be based on the advice of the
lawyers that work with them criminal
activity that is exactly what the house
committee says it found CNN reports the
house select committee investigating the
January 6 2021 attack on the U.S Capitol
has decided to make criminal referrals
to the Department of Justice according
to Congressman Benny Thompson Thompson's
a Mississippi Democrat and said the
committee has not yet narrowed down the
universe of individuals who may be
referred of course that's code for we've
not yet ruled out a criminal referral
against the failed former president
Donald Trump asked whether Thompson
believed any of the witnesses perjured
themselves he said quote that's part of
the discussion
when the panel makes referrals Thompson
said it will be a separate document from
the panel's final report that will be
sent to the doj a select committee
spokesperson confirmed to CNN that
criminal referrals will be considered as
a final part of the panel's work the
spokesperson said quote the committee
has determined that referrals to outside
entities should be considered as a final
part of its work the committee will make
decisions about specifics in the days
ahead a source tells CNN the criminal
referrals the January 6 committee will
ultimately be making quote will be
focused on the main organizers and
leaders of the attack so one of the
major obvious pressing questions is is
Trump seen in this particular context by
this committee based on the work they've
done as one of the main leaders and
organizers of the attack and if so is
there going to be a criminal referral
directly to Donald Trump now it's
important to remind people I have no
interest in aggrandizing or minimizing
what may or may not take place here
the question of course if the doj
receives a criminal referral from the
House of Representatives for Trump
is whether they actually decide to
charge him there's no guarantee just
because a criminal referral is made that
Trump is actually going to be charged
perjury also if indeed it took place uh
by those who did testify if there are if
perjury took place it would be nice to
see perjury charges which are very
difficult to prove but we just don't
know about that many people writing to
me and saying David do you know if the
referrals will be made public or will it
be behind the scenes my understanding
from looking at this article and others
is that it will be a separate document
that will contain the referrals but it
will be made public that the evidence is
public the testimony has been public and
the referrals will also be made public
now I want this all to move quickly
we all do it's been years with a lot of
this stuff at the same time it makes
sense that the January 6 committee has
taken a measured approach they've
calculated it they've done everything by
the book there was strategy and it shows
and this really was carried out in a way
that despite and in the context of
massive Republican obstruction because
remember there was initially a deal to
have significantly more Republican
representation on this committee and
Republicans refused to participate
because they wanted the committee to
focus on different things they had all
sorts of rules that they wanted which
made no sense so ultimately the
committee was assembled with a few
Republicans Adam kinzinger uh Liz Cheney
um is that all now now I don't remember
but in any case it was by their own
doing that this was the format of the
committee now we have a time limit
there's a new house led by Republicans
which will be sworn in within a few
weeks this is the end of the committee
but it may only be the beginning of the
Criminal part as far as the doj is
concerned next up let's see what the
referrals show and then go from there we
will have all of today's stories and the
clips and feedback and more
on the Facebook page make sure you have
liked the David packman show on Facebook
at facebook.com
slash slash is important and adapt to
forward slash not a backslash David
Pacman show quick break and be right
back
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show I'm going
to show you an incredible incredible
video in which the mother of a fallen
Capital Riot officer refuses to shake
Mitch McConnell's hand and so do others
and they walk right by it's truly
incredible stuff to see as Newsweek
reports the mother of a fallen Capital
police officer refused to shake the
hands of two Republican lawmakers during
yesterday's Congressional gold medal
ceremony honoring the officers who
defended the capital during the January
6 riot Gladys sicknick the mother of
Brian sicknick that was the U.S Capitol
officer who died of a stroke following
the riot did not accept a handshake
offered by Mitch McConnell and by
representative Kevin McCarthy
they of course were part of the movement
that led to the riots we have the video
here and it is
it's really something uh I'm going to
play it and as you will see
there are individuals here who
um first greet Chuck Schumer and then
they continue on by you see that it is
Schumer and then it is McConnell and
then it is McCarthy and you see Mitch
McConnell stick out his hand and then
you see people just walk by you see
people walk by there is another there is
Gladys picnic she walks by and then they
just continue to walk by and Mitch
McConnell's standing there he's really
you know they say Joe Biden shook hands
with the air
there is Applause
it is really uh Mitch McConnell there
shaking hands with the air now
um we actually heard from Brian's
brother Ken sicknick who was asked what
was that about why didn't you shake
hands and he says well it's pretty
self-evident but I'll tell you anyway
take a listen to this
[Music]
[Music]
whatever
hold
that Trump has on them they've backed up
against or what it's meant to wrong
going not necessarily them themselves
but of trump all the Riders I mean
people like people like Louis Bowman who
presented the American flag that was
flown over the capitol through January
6th Friday
he told them they were a patron
disgusting and that's the way everything
my brother's done takes away my blood
the heroism my father showed you know
you don't think you don't think they
deserved a handshake in this context
well no
no no what are you even saying by
shaking their hands like what it would
it really it actually doesn't make any
sense because unlike Liz Cheney they
have no idea what Integrity is they
can't stand up for what's right and
wrong but it's no the devil's party
first let's give up for political career
to do almost right and try to find this
room she's she's the one railroad
powering the whole committee that they
can show Integrity that they can show
they actually care about
process about democracy about everything
that goes on and these guys are as low
as it's got a Big R in front of it we're
going to do it underneath hard to argue
against what he's saying and this entire
January 6th Riot Fiasco which now is
going on nearly two years I mean we're
getting closer to the two-year
anniversary of the riots it feels like
it was just yesterday it has been
emblematic of the absolute worst of the
Republican party it's been emblematic of
we just say stuff but we don't really
have values We Stand by such as we're
for Law and Order
until hundreds of their supporters
rioted committing various crimes on
January 6 2021 all of a sudden they're
defending those people we are for uh
backing the blue and supporting law
enforcement until all of a sudden the
targets of their followers were Capital
police and and of course as we know with
the FBI that's also been a popular
Target as well every single one of these
stated principles and values that they
hold dear and they love to talk about
here are principles and they we can the
Constitution
well they want the Constitution thrown
out that was part of what the riots were
for at the end of the day whether
overtly or implicitly they wanted the
person who won based on the process
outlined by the Constitution to not get
the office that they won and they wanted
the guy that lost Donald Trump to be the
president
but we care about the Constitution well
not when it's inconvenient but we
support law enforcement well not when
it's inconvenient we support Law and
Order not when it's inconvenient and
then now all of a sudden they say oh
pre-trial detention the conditions these
rioters are being held in are unfair
well we've been talking about that for
over a decade on the program
and you insist oh listen if you get
charged with a crime it's probably
because you're guilty and you deserve
whatever conditions there are and you're
too dangerous to be let out on pre-trial
uh you you have to be held in pre-trial
detention
endless endless and uh now this is the
outcome and fortunately or unfortunately
or whatever it's a lesson that they are
learning but that they're not really
appearing to learn anything from Fox
News visibly and brazenly continues to
lie about the Twitter bombshell Twitter
files which flopped softer than a wet
noodle
um this one is going to be I I know that
this isn't going to work as well for
people just listening today because
there's a visual component here play
along for a moment and then I'll explain
it all to you I'm gonna play a clip for
you of Ted Cruz Cancun Cruz a senator
from Texas appearing on Fox News this
was uh yesterday
to talk about the Twitter files and if
you're watching keep an eye on the
screen
and see if you can identify something
weird on the screen
let's listen and then we are going to
discuss
look Jesse what what Elon Musk has
released is evidence of corruption that
goes to the highest level of government
it goes to the highest level of the FBI
and it goes to the highest level of big
Tech we've known for a long time that
big Tech is censoring conservatives but
what Elon did here is he just laid naked
all of the lies that the corporate media
has told because it's clear during the
2020 election over and over and over
again the Biden the Biden campaign and
the DNC would reach out to their buddies
at Twitter and say hey we don't like
this and their response is handled and
they take it down over and over and over
again and in particular all of the
exchange back and forth when the hunter
Biden laptop story broke it was evidence
that the leadership at Twitter knew
within hours that that their ridiculous
fake excuse that it was hacked was a
ridiculous fake excuse to eat wow I mean
it's I don't know that there's anything
true in what Ted Cruz is saying but let
me call your attention to a couple of
different things at the start of the
segment the title at the bottom of the
screen that fox puts up says Biden White
House
had Direct Line
to Twitter sensors okay what Biden White
House what Biden White House this all
took place in 2020 when Joe Biden was
not the president of the United States
there was no Biden White House now you
want to write this off as some kind of
technicality because it's really not
there is no such entity as the Biden
White House unless you believe in some
kind of strange time travel that
Democrats had access to in 2020.
also direct line
they had an email address
they had an email address and as I've
said before
if you want to make the case that a
political campaign not an Administration
that a political campaign the Biden
campaign
should have had to use the same system I
have to use right like you know on
Twitter we're on Twitter right now if I
don't like a tweet I have to click the
little thing and then report tweet right
and I gotta fill out a form and do a
whole different thing if you want to
make the case that they should have had
to do that rather than emailing someone
at Twitter when revenge porn of Hunter
Biden was posted I'm glad to have that
conversation with you maybe that's true
maybe they should have to do the same
thing I have to do rather than email
someone but that's not really a
bombshell that's a little issue around
the edges the main story here
is not really a story this was about
content nude images of Hunter Biden that
he didn't release
that violates Twitter's guidelines about
revenge porn it's content that was
illegal in just about every state in the
United States and I believe against
federal law as well although I'd have to
refresh my memory on that back from the
start of the hunter Biden story
um and and the entire story Biden White
House didn't exist direct line it was an
email address this exposes corruption at
the highest levels
not really maybe they should have had to
use the report tweet function rather
than an email
it flopped and again I don't know if Ted
Cruz knows it flopped but is lying or
doesn't realize that it flopped Ted Cruz
is smart enough
to probably realize that so I would lean
on he's being dishonest rather than
ignorant but with Ted Cruz you never
really know we have a voicemail number
and that number is 2192 David P I had
slash have covid as many of you know
every day I've been doing a little bit
better my voice a little bit stronger
every day
and our friend Eric from Mass who has
been warning me I'm going to end up in
prison because of the things I said
about the vaccine has a new message for
me and the message is the vaccine gave
me covid apparently on a very long delay
take a listen
hey David I saw your video you know you
were pretty rough man you got covered
from the vaccine
80 to 90 The Washington Post came out
and said uh people getting uh
go over to from people who uh got
vaccinated against Coleman yeah uh
I don't know what what he's talking
about but okay
um
yeah I hope you feel about it buddy
um I told you not to get that truck
yep uh I am feeling better and you know
I said at the beginning of the week
I got emails from people saying David
this is proof the vaccine doesn't work
because you got coveted anyway
and other people who wrote in and said
you should be glad you were vaccinated
because you on average probably had a
milder case now being Beyond it
hopefully barring any kind of rebound
if I really zoom out
I was very sick
for about 26 hours
and it does seem completely plausible
and in line with the science that the
reason I was really only down in bed for
26 hours would be that I received this
bivalent booster targeted specifically
to Omicron just a couple of months ago
now listen I'm right with everybody when
we talk about vaccination and we say hey
you know what we vaccinate kids against
Hep B and they don't get Hep B and we
vaccinate kids against measles and they
don't get measles
yes at some point I hope and believe it
obviously is the goal to get to a
coveted vaccine that is like that uh but
absent that
something that people end up
hospitalized with and people die with
and at the end of the day I was really
sick with a fever 26 or 28 hours during
which I watched four World Cup games in
one movie
um
completely plausible that that is indeed
because of the vaccine obviously this is
a sample of one I can't go back and have
the covid without the vaccination to see
how bad it would have been I also have
no interest in doing that we have a
voicemail number I'm sorry we we have a
bonus show today that was the voicemail
we have a bonus show today we're going
to talk about the Taylor Swift uh
Ticketmaster Fiasco interesting story
about Monopoly power big Tech so many
different things we'll talk about that
Cherokee Nation wants to send a delegate
to the House of Representatives we will
talk about the context and the history
of such representatives and uh Madison
cawthorne outgoing failed member of
Congress Madison cawthorne has been
directed to pay a fine for an improper
cryptocurrency purchase what is it all
about what did he do what did he say why
does he have to pay a fine and does the
house have the authority to make him pay
such a fine all of those stories when I
am joined by producer Pat on today's
bonus show sign up at joinpackman.com it
is a beautiful thing
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors give directly is
the non-profit that lets you send cash
directly to the world's poorest
household which is more cost effective
than so many other types of giving it's
how you know you're maximizing your
donations help us reach our goal of
fifteen thousand dollars by the end of
the year go to give
directly.org Pacman